hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen if you're Canadian like
me you are getting ready to celebrate
Thanksgiving and it is super exciting
because who doesn't love a good turkey
day and if you're American well your
president sucks but also you're gonna
have to wait a few more weeks but either
way no matter where you're celebrating I
have an amazing recipe that is totally
gonna blow the socks off all of your
guests if you're entertaining a huge
group chances are you're gonna have at
least one person who's not eating the
turkey because they're vegan and one
person who's not eating the stuffing
because they're gluten free and like a
whole bunch of people who are not eating
much of anything because they're sitting
at the kids table waiting on their
chicken nuggets well I can't help you
with that last one
the first two I am totally gonna nail
here because I have an awesome vegan
gluten free stuff acorn squash recipe
that everyone at the dinner table is
gonna love let's do this I start by
cutting my acorn squash in half then I
take all the seeds out into a bowl you
can save those things for later I topped
them off with a little bit of salt and
pepper on the insides and place them cut
side down onto a baking sheet lined with
tin foil and cover it with a little bit
more foil pop it into a 415 degree oven
for about 45 to 50 minutes
next I add some olive oil to a pan and
add in my sliced onion cooking it low
and slow for about 45 to 50 minutes
until caramelized now it's time to
finish the filling I add some olive oil
to a pan with some mushrooms garlic and
some sage and I saute that up until
everything is caramelized and golden
then I add in a lot of green apple and
some baby kale leaves and I give it a
good stir to wilt those kale down
then I transfer everything to a big bowl
for mixing and I add in some cooked wild
rice some cooked white beans some
caramelized onions my dried cranberries
some pomegranate arils some chopped
pecans pomegranate molasses and some
salt and pepper give it one last stir to
incorporate all those flavors and now
it's time to stuff so to my cooked acorn
squash tabs I add all of that beautiful
stuffing stuff it right to the brim so
it's basically overflowing then I give
it another little drizzle of that sticky
pomegranate molasses and I pop it back
into the oven for about 15 minutes look
how good that looks well there you have
it folks you are totally gonna make it
through Thanksgiving this year
because new we've got an awesome recipe
that everybody at the dinner table is
going to love and we've got so much to
be thankful for speaking of being
thankful I have a very special
announcement that I cannot wait to share
with you guys on the channel so be sure
to check back next week to find out what
it is if you love this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below some of the alternative
Thanksgiving means that you make for
people with food intolerances in your
life subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]